(audience claps)
- Welcome back to New
York and Premiere Week
at the Kelly Clarkson show!
We are here with NBC Nightly News
anchor and Dateline host,
Lester Holt. Give it up!
(audience cheers)
And speaking of news, many
events in music have been so big
that they've made
headlines around the world.
So we thought we'd play a game
about a few big musical
moments of history.
It's called "Rhythm and News."
♪ Rhythm and News ♪
(audience cheers)
- Jesse showed up for Season Four, y'all.
She is ready. I like that one.
(Lester laughs)
Rhythm and blues, rhythm
and news, it's funny.
I like it. Uh, we need a host.
So here to do the honors
is a very talented actress
you know from "The Good
Place," and the new
"A League of Their Own"
on Prime Video, D'Arcy Carden, y'all!
(audience cheers)
(cheerful music)
- [Kelly] Alright!
(audience cheers)
- Hey!
- Have y'all met?
- [Lester] We just met!
- We just met!
- Okay! You go way back.
- Oh, yeah!
- Not but 10 seconds ago.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- But it feels deep.
- But there was a moment there.
- I could feel a connection.
That's what we're all about here.
(Lester laughs)
Can you tell us about the game?
- Oh yeah, sure, absolutely.
- Okay, yeah.
Of course I can. I can
tell you about this game.
You made it up.
- Of course I can.
I will ask some questions
about some of the
most talked-about stories in music
in the last hundred years.
That's really important.
- She pointed at me on the
hundreds, did you notice that?
(women laugh)
- What? Okay.
- If you know the answer,
hit the button and take a guess,
but if you're wrong, the
other person can steal.
Kelly is playing for the
left side of the audience,
(audience cheers)
and Lester is playing for the right,
and the winner will earn a pair of tickets
to the hit Broadway musical, Wicked
(audience cheers)
for each person on their
side of the audience.
That's cool.
- Okay.
- Okay?
- Okay!
- Okay! Here we go!
- No looking at prompter. No cheaters!
- Oh yeah, it's not in the prompter.
I made sure of it.
- Okay.
- Just in case. That happens sometimes.
- Not today!
- Okay. Not gonna call out the
celebrity, but they cheated.
- Tell me, tell me.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah, I'll tell you later.
- Now that I know the secret, but
(All laugh)
- Okay, y'all ready? Make eye contact.
- Okay.
- Yeah, let's do this.
- [Kelly] Do you see this? Yeah.
- Blow each other a kiss.
(Lester blows a kiss)
- Yeah. I'm not kissing,
I'm not blowing no kiss.
- I was just- my hair.
(audience laughs)
- Okay. Here we go. First question.
In 1982, this rocker made headlines
when he bit the head off-
(buttons slam)
(phone rings)
- Uh, the- a bat! Um, um,
oh God, oh God, Ozzy-born.
Ozzy-born. Osbourne.
Um, um, Ozzy Osbourne!
- Yes!
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- When he bit the head
- What?
- Off-
- What did I just say?
- I like that.
- I know who Ozzy Osbourne
is. What just happened?
- You're in it.
- I just panicked.
- Shall we continue?
- Yes.
- Okay. Keep it together.
(audience laughs)
Second question. In February, 1964,
73 million people tuned
in to the Ed Sullivan Show
to see the U.S. premiere
(phone rings)
- Oh.
- The Beatles.
- That's right.
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- I didn't even. I was
gonna like, guess Beatles,
- Yeah.
- Cause it felt like a,
- A huge moment, but-
- 64 begins my kind of-
- Right, right, right.
- Birth of knowledge.
- Right.
- No, not mine.
(all laugh)
- I was like, dang it. Loser loser.
- Alright. After a dispute
with her record label,
this singer songwriter,
rerecorded many of her-
(phone rings)
(audience gasps)
- You better, you better be quiet.
- That's because it
might have been my idea.
I hope I'm right. I'm gonna
look like a tool if I'm not.
Taylor Swift.
- That's right.
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- Hey!
- Okay. .
- You knew it.
- Alright, cool.
- That one, that one was
kinda not fair because-
- Okay.
- Yeah. My producers are nice to me.
They didn't wanna me to lose too badly.
(all laugh)
That one is kind of
not fair because I did,
I was like, you should do
that, and then she did it.
Nobody ever listens to me.
- She did.
- Yeah.
- She really did.
- She, she did. And it worked.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. For all of us.
(audience cheers)
- Okay.
- Okay. At super bowl
38, these two musicians
made headlines that still won't
(phone rings)
- Uh huh?
- Justin Timberlake and Janet Jackson.
- That's right.
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- That was good.
- Wow. Wow. Um, shall we continue?
- Sure.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- We shall.
- This digital music sharing platform
changed the industry forever when it-
(buttons slam)
(phone rings)
- Spotify.
(buzzer sounds)
- Napster.
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- Well guess who's not coming back
to the Kelly Clarkson Show anymore?
(all laugh)
(audience cheers)
- I didn't, I didn't let,
I didn't allow the
question to be finished.
- Who remembers Napster?
(all laugh)
- Lester Holt.
- Ugh.
- And guess what? Lester is the winner.
- Lester.
(brass music)
(audience cheers)
- But, fear not, audience
members on my side,
because you are all winners
when it comes to daytime TV,
so you are all going home with two tickets
to see Wicked, Broadway's
biggest blockbuster,
(audience cheers)
which kicks off its twentieth
anniversary in October.
It's a great show. You're gonna love it.